hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel it is a warm sunny day here in
Chicago which is unusual considering it
is normally a desolate Tundra
additionally it seems like a fine day
for all of us to talk about multi-leader
replication now personally I'm not a big
fan of multi-leader replication because
as an Alpha Sigma male myself I actually
don't believe in having multiple leaders
clearly such a setup is destined to fail
as you can see in this video there are
many problems with multi-leader
replication regardless of the advantages
that it does bring so let's go ahead
bring the iPad out and talk about all of
them alrighty so as I mentioned today
we're going to be talking about
multi-leader replication
and let's go ahead and get into it so
let's start out with a basic diagram of
what multi-leader replication actually
looks like as you can see we've got a
few leader nodes
where the leaders can be marked with L's
and of course we have some follower
nodes as well where the followers can be
marked with f
so what does multi-leader replication
actually get us well basically the point
here is that anyone can write to any of
the leaders and they can write anything
and of course we can still only read
from the followers and the followers are
going to be getting those rights
propagated to them probably
asynchronously so again what does this
afford US it affords us more right
throughput why because now we can write
to a bunch of different places and
additionally another thing that's really
nice about this is say we've got a user
in Europe we've got a user in North
America and one in Africa the guy who's
in Europe doesn't have to go ahead and
write all the way to North America
because obviously those are further
apart it's going to take a longer amount
of time for his message to cross all of
those internet cables and having leaders
in all of these different places may
make life a lot more convenient so as
you can see in this case though the
leaders themselves
are not exactly isolated either right
they're still passing their rights from
one to another and there are many
different configurations in which they
can actually pass these rights from one
to another so let's go ahead and start
talking about them so the first and most
basic that we'll talk about is the
circle topology so this is pretty simple
basically imagine all of these nodes
that I have in this graph are liters and
they're going to go ahead and pass
rights to one another so you know we've
got rights coming from here we've got
rights coming from here but of course
this does beg the question what if I
killed one node let's say I went ahead
tripped on a power cable and now this
guy is gone well shoot it just occurred
to me that this guy right here is
relying on the existence of this node in
order to get his rights over to this guy
so now all of a sudden our system cannot
move forward right rights are no longer
going to be propagated around our
multi-leader setup and we've basically
just screwed ourselves so that's the
issue Circle topology is basically have
no no kind of durability or protection
against one single node failure so what
can we actually do to make this better
well of course another possible solution
is the star topology
so why is this another solution well
let's go ahead and kill some nodes let's
say that the point of the star topology
keep in mind is we've got one Center
node right which you can see right here
and then a bunch of outer nodes that are
passing all of their rights to the
center node and then the center node in
turn is going to distribute them to the
rest of the nodes in the star topology
if I were to go ahead and kill this guy
right here well it's no big deal because
these two can actually still go ahead
and communicate with each other right
it's fine right all of the star is still
maintained on the other hand of course
we are still susceptible to one major
failure which is the center of the star
because if this guy goes down right I go
ahead and nuke that now all of a sudden
these two databases can no longer
communicate with each other because
they're both sending messages to that
Center node the center node isn't
responding and they're saying
we're out of luck okay so what can we do
that's possibly even better than that
well
the all to all topology
now this thing is where pandemonium
really starts to go crazy you know
they're sending messages around like I
send DMS to girls on Instagram
as you can see if a single node goes
down it's actually not an issue why
because they're all communicating with
each other anyway that being said there
is still a problem of kind of causality
right where so for example let's say uh
this guy has a message a written to it
and then this guy is going to receive a
and then now all of a sudden someone
writes uh B on top of a okay and then
this guy then passes B over to this note
over here and yet this guy still hasn't
even received a yet right so a is going
very slow but it's still only over here
so now we have an issue where this
database has received a message B that
is causally dependent on the message a
so it is possible for our rights to get
out of order and this is something
that's fixable but it's going to take
quite a bit of thinking to get done and
it's something that I'll talk more about
in the next video so you know this whole
causality thing it's not a huge point
but the main issue here is keep in mind
that when you're passing messages all
around indiscriminately things can get
out of order and out of whack so with
that in mind well how actually can they
get out of order and out of whack and
how can we make sure that when messages
are bouncing around the databases all
over the place right because we've got
things going up and down and side to
side and they're coming back we want to
make sure that all of these rights are
not being applied multiple times on
every single database node so we
actually have to go ahead and make a
change to the replication log to ensure
that rights aren't being bounced around
forever so every single database can
obviously keep track of which rights its
apply it but you know it's probably
going to take that right that it gets in
and send it to all the other database
nodes if it thinks that they haven't
seen it yet so what can we actually do
well we can modify our replication log
to actually keep track of which rights
in the replication log have been seen by
which database nodes so let's say we've
got five nodes one example of what we
can do right here let's say in the
replication log we're writing you know
Jordan is equal to sexy obviously and
then what we would do is in a
multi-leader setup we can actually add
the fact that as this right kind of goes
to a specific database node that it's
been seen by that database node so this
way you know once one two one three and
five goes to one two three four five any
database that receives that right is now
not going to send it out any further so
that's the only way we can ensure that
there's not going to be effectively just
like an infinite Loop of a ton of Rights
being sent around and clogging our
system and screwing things up so that is
very useful basically it answers which
replicas have seen the right as best as
we are aware and that makes sure that we
aren't just passing the message around
indefinitely and possibly even applying
it more than once because that could be
really problematic
okay so kind of the elephant in the room
that I haven't spoken about so far is
the issue with their basically being two
leaders right and what two leaders leads
to is Right conflicts because we can now
write to multiple places so let's look
at a quick example of this as I try and
scroll and whatnot so we've got leader
one right here we've got leader two over
here what is a right conflict well let's
say I've got one guy probably myself
writing that Jordan is Alpha to leader
one and then we've got a second guy
probably a major coward writing to L2
that Jordan is beta so when L1 and L2
eventually pass rights to each other as
we know they will regardless of the
topology
how do we actually know whether Jordan
is Alpha or Jordan is beta because they
were written basically at the same time
we're assuming actually that the person
who wrote Jordan is Alpha does not know
about the Jordan is beta right when they
wrote it and Sam goes for the Jordan is
beta writer what this effectively means
is that these two rights are concurrent
and now we have to resolve a right
conflict between them
so which one is actually going to be the
winner well one easy solution is
actually known as conflict avoidance
and What conflict avoidance does is
basically says that all rights to the
same key are going to the same replica
right so the way we could actually avoid
this situation is by instead of letting
this guy write Jordan equals beta to L2
he has to write it to L1 because then we
know that alpha or beta is going to get
there first and then one of them is
going to win
on the other hand this is actually going
to limit the type of write throughput
that we have right because if all of our
guys have to write to the same replica
for the same key you know let's say this
guy over here is in Africa now he has to
write to North America and it's going to
take a little bit longer what we've
effectively done here is partition the
database and partitioning is something
we're going to talk about a lot in the
future but for now let's not really
think about this strategy too much
because more so what we care about is
actually resolving right conflicts so
let's think about a way that we can do
it well one strategy that I often see
mentioned is last right wins so every
single right to a database is going to
have a time stamp right you know I'm
writing Jordan equals Alpha at four
o'clock P.M and so what we can use is
that time stamp to decide right if I
write Jordan's Alpha at four o'clock and
someone writes Jordan as beta at 401
well it turns out Jordan is beta is the
more up-to-date value So in theory this
does work right however in reality
there's actually a lot of problems the
first problem is what time stamp do we
actually use do we use the timestamp of
the sender well probably not this isn't
a great idea because if we use the
timestamp of the sender someone can
actually just like purposely manipulate
their device timestamp you know for
example if I always wanted to make sure
that the value for Jordan was Alpha I
could just go ahead and change my device
timestamp to 2100 because now all of a
sudden I'm 77 years in the future and my
right is pretty much always going to win
for the next 77 years on the other hand
we could use the timestamp of the
receiver right we could actually use the
timestamp on the two individual leader
nodes in order to determine which right
was more recent now yes technically this
does work if of course we could rely on
those timestamps so it turns out we
actually can and why is this we're
actually going to do a little bit of a
deep dive into computer hardware
so basically clocks in computers are run
on something called a quartz crystal and
the quartz crystal is set to vibrate at
a certain frequency that allows the
computer to tell how much time has
elapsed between two periods so that's
really useful that being said this
quartz crystal is not perfect in
response to certain changes in the
weather and just randomly over time the
frequency that it vibrates can actually
change a little bit that's known as
clock skew so actually the computer time
stamp can you know be a few nanoseconds
or milliseconds a little bit away from
the actual time that it should be and
this itself turns out to be a problem
why is that well obviously if we can't
rely on our time stamps on our computers
it means that say I may have written the
right later than someone else calling me
beta however it turns out that that
computer or that leader that the beta
right went to just happened to have a
later time step so what do we actually
do because clock skew is a serious
problem in modern Computing well
frequently what we would do let's take
my cell phone over here and you know
we've got a time that says four o'clock
however we know it's really supposed to
be 359 right or 358 rather so what we
would typically do is we would perform a
network request over ntp which is
Network time protocol so ntp allows us
to ask some sort of global time server
which has a GPS clock which is going to
be a lot more accurate than quartz drift
and then we can actually go ahead and
adjust our computer clock in response to
that so this allows us to at least stay
pretty close to the actual time however
even this isn't perfect because ntp
implies that we are making that request
over a network and by making a request
over a network we are subject to network
delay so you can see right here that
even if ntp tells us it's 358 if we have
a one second delay now all of a sudden
on my phone I think it's 359 which is
still wrong and what this means is that
all of a sudden the time on your device
can literally jump backwards in time and
so if you're doing this it's not very
reliable for trying to build a robust
application we can't order rights this
way because just basically randomly in
response to the time on your computer
which isn't accurate you can just lose
rights right like the Jordan is beta
right if it were to lose there would
just be lost forever and we wouldn't
even know it existed so it's very
important that our time stamps be
accurate except the truth of the matter
is it's not very easy to do so
so again this leads to Lost rights at
the end of the day now I am going to
stop the video here because the truth of
the matter is there's not a great
solution to solving right conflicts
we're going to talk about in the next
video some more in-depth ways of doing
so and there are some pretty clever
tricks to be able to identify two rights
that have occurred concurrently but
there's no hard and fast rule to look at
two rights and say hey one definitely
came before the other and here's how we
know there are some databases that have
kind of tried doing this and they are
making some progress but they're pretty
Niche Hardware decisions for the most
part and we will talk about those
eventually too anyways guys I hope you
have a great rest of the day I will see
you in the next one and uh yeah keep
grinding